This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English.
I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
Sam, does this situation sound familiar?
It's a colleague's birthday next week.
A male boss says to a female employee,
you're great at organizing things,
would you buy a card and get everyone in the office to sign it?
Oh, and we'll need to order a cake too.
Thanks, you're amazing.
Yes, I have seen that.
A male boss asks a woman to do all the jobs
that keep the office running,
but do nothing to advance her career
or improve her chances of promotion.
That's when someone moves up into a higher,
better paid position in a company.
Sadly, this happens a lot.
In many workplaces around the world,
it's the men who are considered born leaders
and promoted up the corporate career ladder,
while the women are given less important roles.
Even today, many working women find themselves
at a point in their career
beyond which they cannot progress.
An invisible barrier to succeed
referred to as the glass ceiling.
This in this programme will be meeting the members of the No Club,
a group of women saying,
no, to the glass ceiling,
by publicly questioning the kinds of jobs men and women
are asked to do in the workplace.
And of course, we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first, I have a question for you, Sam.
Despite the glass ceiling,
women do make it to the top jobs
in many areas of work and business,
even in the male-dominated world of politics.
So, who was the first woman to become British Prime Minister?
Was it A, Theresa May,
B, Nicholas Sturgeon, or C, Margaret Thachar?
Hmm, I know the answer to this one, Neil.
It's C, Margaret Thachar.
OK, well, we'll find out later if you're right.
Professor Lee's Vestelund is one of the four academics
who co-wrote the No Club,
a book discussing how females disproportionately
take on the unimportant, less visible tasks at work.
Professor Vestelund calls these non-promotable tasks,
jobs like taking notes,
organizing social events or sharing meetings,
jobs that take time and effort,
but do little to increase company profits,
or to boost your career.
Research shows that most of these tasks are done by women.
Here's Lee's Vestelund,
explaining more to BBC World Service Programme, business daily.
We've been noticing gender differences in wages,
in advance management, in negotiation,
burnout for women is much greater than it is for men.
They're just satisfaction with their work is much greater.
And we've been trying to sort of address all these objectives
with lots of different methods and techniques,
and what is interesting about the non-promotable work
is that it's sort of in a very structural sense
contributes to all of those differences.
Professor Vestelund lists some workplace gender imbalances,
including job dissatisfaction and burnout.
That's tiredness and exhaustion caused by working too hard.
Many of these issues are made worse by non-promotable tasks.
Natalie Quail agrees.
Natalie started her successful dental cosmetics company,
Smile Time, after winning a business competition
on the TV show, Dragon's Den.
Here she tells BBC World Services Business Daily
about her experience of being asked to take on
non-promotable tasks in her work
as a trainee solicitor.
As a trainee solicitor,
pretty much every task that you take on
is a non-promotable task.
Note-taking gets one of them in meetings
where you're kind of told,
like, you can't really speak or say anything.
I was tasked with being their team party organizer,
so that was my role.
It does definitely occur that the women and the team,
the level of multitasking they're doing
is just far outstrips the men in a lot of cases,
for example, you know,
a lot of women in the team would also be juggling,
having kids at home, being a working mom.
Natalie found herself doing non-promotable tasks.
She thinks many women in the workplace
are expected to be good at multitasking,
doing more than one thing at the same time.
For working moms who are raising a family,
as well as developing careers at work,
this involves some juggling,
trying to manage your life
when you're involved in many different activities,
which all demand your time.
In the 40 years since the term glass ceiling was invented,
it seems not much has changed for working women.
But there is some good news.
The number of female managers and women working
in jobs traditionally seen as male
has increased dramatically.
And those companies where getting promotion
is based on ability, not gender,
have benefited from talented, hardworking female leaders.
And speaking of female leaders, Neil,
what was the answer to your question?
You asked me who was the first female British Prime Minister,
and I said, Margaret Thatcher, was I right.
You were right. Mrs. Thatcher nicknamed the Iron Lady,
became Prime Minister in May 1979.
The first woman to break the political glass ceiling
in the UK, an invisible barrier to advancing in your career.
OK, let's recap the other vocabulary we've learnt,
starting with promotion,
moving up into a higher, more important position
in your company.
The term non-promotable tasks describes
those unimportant jobs which help your organisation
that do nothing to advance your career.
They are often given to women.
If you have burnout, you're exhausted from working too hard.
Multi-tasking is the ability to do several things
at the same time.
And finally, juggling involves managing
many different activities which all demand your time.
We've managed our time pretty well so far,
but now our six minutes are up.
Bye for now.
Bye.
Six new English from the BBC.